So I want you to imagine holding a cup of ice cold water on just a relentlessly scorching day.
Right.
You bring it right up to your lips, but before you can even take a single sip, the sheer weight of what that water actually represents makes you lose consciousness.
Yeah, completely pass out.
Exactly.
And that is not a metaphor.
I mean, that is the exact historical moment where our deep dive begins.
It is.
Hello and.
today we are stepping into a deeply uncompromising text from the master who wrote this letter to his student.
It's in the work known as O Beloved Son.
Yes.
And we're really examining that exact juncture where all the studying, all the reading and the intellectual accumulation of facts
It suddenly demands to be made physical.
Right, the physical reality of it.
Yeah, because the cure to knowledge that you just haven't acted upon, it begins, well, to begin with another textbook, it begins with a sip of cold water in the hand of a saint who simply cannot bear it.
Worship is another name for obedience.
Right, I mean, that is the absolute spine of what we're mapping out today.
It's the core of everything we're about to discuss.
Like you hold knowledge, you've read the books, you understand the concepts, right?
Dab the theory down.
Exactly.
But how does the physical body
actually enact what the mind supposedly knows.
That's the real friction.
It is.
Because it's one thing to possess this massive library of spiritual facts, but it is entirely another to let those facts reorder the way you breathe.
The way you sleep.
The way you wake up in the morning.
Right.
So we are going to examine the map of this, moving from that sudden bodily shock of the water through the silent watches of the night, St.
into the absolute requirement of the prophetic frame.
And ultimately we have to confront the inward sword.
Yeah, the sword that has to sever the lower self.
Well, the text we are examining diagnoses a very specific and honestly a very fatal paralysis.
Okay, fatal in what sense?
It is the disease of the scholar who knows everything but does absolutely nothing.
Wow.
Yeah, that's a common disease.
Right.
The text has already established in previous sections that knowledge without action isn't just useless.
It's worse than useless.
Exactly.
It's an act of liability.
It actually brings severe judgment.
So it's not a neutral state.
Not at all.
So the master, he doesn't begin his prescription for this disease with like a new definition or some new conceptual framework.
Because the student already has too many frameworks.
Precisely.
He knows the student is drowning in framework.
So he begins with a scene.
He gives us the early Bazran teacher.
Right.
And I really want us to sit with this scene for a minute because it forces us to interrogate the actual mechanics of true realization.
It does.
So the early Bazran teacher is handed this cold, sweet drink.
I mean, it's just a simple human comfort.
Just a glass of water.
But the moment he takes this cup in his hand,
Before he even drinks, he just, he lets out this deep, heavy sigh.
And he falls completely unconscious.
Right.
And when he finally comes to, you know, when the people around him rush in to ask what on earth happened to him, he explains himself.
And his explanation is terrifying.
It really is.
He says he remembered the plea of the inhabitants of hell when they will besiege the inhabitants of paradise to pour upon them even a little water.
We really need to analyze why the masters
starts the instruction of his student right here.
With this specific physical collapse.
Right, because he has spent chapters diagnosing the intellectual failure of unapplied knowledge.
Yeah, all the theory.
Right.
The disciple has been shown through parables and verses that his learning is entirely hollow if it just stays in his head.
So the cure has to bypass the brain entirely.
Exactly.
It must be physical.
Notice the early Basran teacher doesn't reject the cup.
Oh, that's true.
He doesn't bat it away.
Not making some theatrical display of asceticism, he receives it.
Right.
But in the act of receiving that physical comfort, he is struck by this unbearable consciousness.
The coldness of the water.
The coldness, the condensation on the outside of the cup, the sweetness of it.
All just hits him at once.
It triggers the realization of the absolute unbridgeable gulf between his present comfort and the eternal deprivation of those who are denied it.
You know, I want to pause on the involuntary nature of this.
Sure.
Because
Why does the path of spiritual action begin with a bodily reflex, like swooning, falling unconscious, sighing heavily?
These aren't deliberate choices.
No, they aren't.
He doesn't just sit down and look at the cup and decide, I'm going to feel overwhelmed right now.
Well, the path requires a soul that pays attention at a level far deeper than conscious calculation.
Okay, so deeper than just thinking about it.
Right.
I mean, for most of us, knowledge sits very comfortably in the prefrontal cortex.
It's an abstraction.
Yeah, it's just data.
Exactly.
The intellectual knowledge of the afterlife, the knowledge of paradise and hell, something the early Basran teacher already possessed.
He had probably taught it thousands.
he had.
But in that specific moment, the knowledge dropped from his intellect into his chest.
It was throat.
Into his nervous system.
It became a physical wakefulness.
Oh wow.
an idea can be debated.
It can be ignored.
You can put it in a neat little theological box.
Exactly.
But when the reality of that idea grips your biology, when it literally makes you heave and lose consciousness, it is no longer just an idea.
It's an experienced reality.
Yes.
So the knowledge is no longer carried in the brain, it's carried in the bones.
That's a great way to put it.
And the contrast is what breaks him.
Like the cup will never reach those who are begging for it.
Never.
And feeling the cold.
cold water in his own hand is the bridge that just short circuits his entire system.
It's A profound shift from knowing about a reality to bearing the actual crushing weight of it.
And from that deeply internal, intensely physical moment, the master then turns the student's attention outward.
Okay, so moving away from the internal nervous system.
Right.
He shifts to the external structure of the day.
Specifically, he focuses on the darkness before the dawn.
The night watch.
Yes.
He introduces the pre-dawn proclamation.
And he asks this rhetorical but really devastating question to the students.
He asks, if knowledge without action had been sufficient for you and deeds were truly unnecessary, then why would the creator call out at the time before dawn?
Why would the call be is there anyone who repents?
Is there anyone who asks?
Is there anyone who seeks forgiveness?
I mean, it is a standing summons.
It is.
And if we look at it logically, if knowing the facts of the religion were enough to save a person,
There would be no need for a daily scheduled call to action while the rest of the world is unconscious.
Right.
The summons would literally have no addressee.
The court would be convening for an empty room.
Exactly.
And the text reinforces this reality with the Quranic witness.
Which says what exactly?
It describes the true servants as those who sleep but little in the night.
This is the blessed hour of nearness.
And to really drive the point home, the master brings in the story of the praised companion.
Right, so this is a man who is praised directly to the prophet, peace and blessings of Allah be upon him and his family.
Yes, and the response to this praise is incredibly revealing.
Because it wasn't just a simple agreement.
No, the response was a reservation.
A caveat.
Exactly.
The prophet said he is a good man, if only he were to perform the pre-dawn voluntary prayer.
Man, think about what that implies for you, the listener, as someone navigating your own life and your own spiritual worth.
It's a high bar.
It's A terrifying bar.
We are talking about a person who is fundamentally good, someone whose character is so solid, whose interactions are so upright, that other people are praising him to the ultimate spiritual authority.
And yet he is viewed as incomplete.
Right.
The goodness of his character during the daylight hours, you know, his social morality,
It's simply not enough to cover the absence of his vigil in the dark.
Because the text insists that excessive sleep at night leaves its keeper entirely empty-handed on the day of judgment.
Empty-handed.
Yes.
The master outlines the direct command given to the prophet himself to perform this prayer.
And he cites verses that highlight those who plead for forgiveness at this specific hour.
So there's a special status for that time.
There is a divine gratitude extended to those who wake.
An honored mention is given to those who seek forgiveness before the sun ever even rises.
It paints a picture of the night that honestly, it completely shatters how we usually experience it.
How do you mean?
Well, we treat the night as a pause button, you know.
Oh sure, just downtime.
Right, it's a blank space between days.
It's just a time for the body to recover so we can go back to producing and consuming tomorrow.
But the text is insisting that the night is heavily populated.
Highly active.
In fact, there are three specific sounds that the text says are especially pleasing to the Creator.
Yes.
There is the sound of the rooster rousing people, the recitation of the Quran, and the voices seeking forgiveness in those early hours.
And to truly grasp the architecture of this, we really need to look at the cosmological scene presented by the early Kufan aesthetic.
Oh, this part is fascinating.
It is.
He describes a reality that is completely invisible to the sleeping world.
Completely hidden.
He describes a wind that blows in the latter part of the.
A win that is specifically created to carry the voices of those who remember and seek forgiveness directly to the court of Allah.
Wow.
And then he details the four angelic proclamations.
Right.
This is where the structure of the night becomes this narrowing funnel.
I really want us to break that funnel down thoroughly.
We should.
Because honestly, it is a terrifying categorization of humanity.
It sorts all of us into four distinct groups every single night.
Every single night.
So at the beginning of the night, an angel beneath the throne calls out for all worshippers to rise.
And who rises?
Those who are granted divine enablement, they rise.
Okay, so that is the broadest category.
Yes.
The first filter.
The eager ones who just jump at the very first opportunity to stand.
Exactly.
Then the funnel narrows.
Okay.
In the middle of the night, a second angel calls out.
And this call is more specific.
It is for all obedient and devoted servants to rise.
So they join the first group.
Right.
They join in, continuing their vigil until the last blessed portion of the night.
And then it narrows again.
Yes.
At that last blessed portion of the night, a third angel calls out for all who seek forgiveness to rise.
And they do.
They do.
Because this is the hour of desperation.
Yeah, the hour for those who know they are broken and need repair before the sun exposes them.
Beautifully put.
But it is the 4th call that carries the absolute heaviest weight.
The one near dawn.
Yes.
Near dawn, a fourth angel calls out to the heedless ones.
The day is basically broken.
It has.
And the text says they rise from their beds as the dead will rise from their graves.
Imagine a courthouse that only operates when everyone else believes the world is shut down.
That's a great analogy.
Right.
The night is not a passive interval of rest.
It is a continuously convening court.
Summons are being issued hour by hour.
Exactly.
The first summons goes to the most eager.
Then the next to the devoted.
The next to the desperate who need forgiveness.
And if you sleep through all of those?
You are not just resting.
You are actively ignoring a direct escalating summons from the highest authority.
That's a chilling way to realize it.
The heedless are those who only wake up when the physical daylight forces them to and they wake up with the unconsciousness of corpses.
Wow.
Like they are physically animate.
They will brush their teeth.
They will commute to work.
They will talk to their colleagues.
But spiritually,
they are deceased.
It is a stark, unyielding assessment of our daily routine.
It really is.
And to ground this towering cosmological reality into something intensely practical, something that really stings the ego, the master shifts genres here.
What does he do?
He brings in the testament of the wise father, peace of alavi upon him, offering counsel to his son.
The father tells his son a very simple, very cutting thing.
Do not let the rooster prove more intelligent than you.
Go ahead.
Think about what a rooster is.
It is a yard bird.
Right.
It is arguably the least dignified creature on the farm.
It just scratches in the dirt, it pecks at bugs.
Not A majestic eagle.
Exactly.
And yet, the rooster hears the call.
The rooster answers the proclamation of the night.
It does its job.
It wakes up, it fulfills its inherent purpose by rousing others, and it aligns itself with the cosmos.
Meanwhile, humans.
Right.
We have all these alarms, all these sophisticated apps designed to trick our biology into doing what a yardbird does intuitively.
To sleep through that hour, to ignore the summons while the yardbird answers it.
is to actively choose to fall below the rank of a bird in the order of creation.
And the master seals the specific teaching with poetry about the weeping dove.
Oh, I love this imagery.
The dove perches on the branch in the depths of the night and calls out, weeping from the pain of separation from its creator.
And the poet?
The poet looks at himself, lying fast asleep in his comfortable bed, and he calls himself a liar.
Because of the contradiction.
Exactly.
He claims to be a lover of the creator.
He claims to have all this spiritual knowledge, all this theology, all this longing.
Yet his eyes are completely dry while the animals weep.
It is a direct indictment.
It is.
You cannot claim the state of love if you are constantly absent at the hour of the beloved's nearness.
We are just not there.
The physical world around you, the wind carrying the voices, the rooster sounding the alarm, the dove weeping on the branch.
They are all participating in an active, vibrant reality.
And you?
The sleeping human with all your supposed intellect are entirely oblivious to it.
Which brings us to the core principle that the master is trying to impress upon the student.
Right.
We return to the spine verbatim.
Worship is another name for obedience.
So if the dawn watch is the ultimate sign of obedience,
what happens when we try to worship on our own terms?
That's the track.
Right, because if waking up at dawn is the standard, what if I decide I want to be spiritual, but I want to do it my way, does the effort still count?
This naturally bridges us into the structural definition of what worship actually is.
Yes.
Because it's not just about the hour you are awake.
It is about the nature of the action you perform.
The master shifts the focus entirely here.
He states that the purpose of all this instruction is to truly
understand what obedience and worship actually are.
And what's the definition?
It's entirely structural.
Worship is following the prophetic frame in every word, every deed, every silence, and every abstention.
You know, I want to push back on this a little.
Go for it.
Because this challenges a very deep, very pervasive assumption most of us hold today.
We love our autonomy.
Exactly.
We tend to believe that if a person intends to worship purely, you know, if their heart is in the right place,
The outward form shouldn't really matter.
That's a very common sentiment.
Like if I am fasting out of a sincere desire to discipline my body and please the Creator, why does a specific framework matter so much?
Why the technicalities?
Right.
Why can't the sincerity of my heart override the technicalities of the law?
Because the text insists that there is no separate spiritual department where your good intentions override the established law.
No separate department.
No.
The master explains that ordinary life only becomes worship when it conforms to the example.
A prophetic example.
Yes.
Form without the correct frame is not alternative worship.
What is it then?
It is rejection.
Wow.
It is arrogance.
It is asserting that you, with your very limited intellect, know a better way to submit than the way that was divinely ordained by the creator of the intellect.
So you cannot invent your own terms of surrender.
Surrender on your own terms isn't surrender.
Right.
By definition, it means accepting the terms given to you.
Exactly.
And the master proves this by exploring what we can call the edge cases.
Okay, the stress tests for this theory.
Right.
These are the scenarios where the physical form of worship completely betrays the substance of it.
Give me an example.
He presents the first case.
Okay, let's look closely at the friction of this.
That's a perfect example.
A person decides to fast on this specific day of celebration.
Right.
They're undertaking the exact physical form of worship.
I mean, they are abstaining from food and water from dawn to dusk.
Mechanics are identical.
The discomfort is intensely real.
The hunger pangs are real.
The thirst is real.
The suffering is there.
And their intention might even feel incredibly pure to them.
They might think, I am being so devout right now, I am denying my flesh while everyone else is out there indulging.
Yet because the command runs the other way on this specific day, because the divine instruction is to eat, to celebrate, to show gratitude through consumption, the person who fasts earns the label of sinner.
Sinner for fasting.
Yes.
The physical mechanics of the act are identical to a day of prescribed fasting.
The biology of the hunger is identical.
But because the framework is violated, the act is poisoned.
That is wild.
The exact same physical action that elevates you to the highest ranks of piety on a Monday turns you into a rebel and a sinner on a Tuesday.
Exactly.
The action didn't change at all.
The frame changed.
It is mathematically precise.
And he gives a second case to reinforce this prayer
at forbidden hours or places.
Okay, what does that look like?
Well, if a person performs a physical act of prayer after the afternoon prayer before sunset or before the sun rises fully at FAJR, or if they pray on unlawfully occupied ground.
Okay, but physically they are praying.
Yes.
The physical movements are identical to valid prayer.
The standing, the bowing, the prostration, it all looks exactly like high worship.
But the text says this earns the labels of sinner and transgressor.
It does.
It outwardly resembles the ultimate submission, but inwardly it is a transgression because it completely ignores the parameters set by the prophetic frame.
It's doing the right thing at the wrong time.
And this is a profound check on the human ego.
So.
Because we desperately want to believe that our effort alone is what counts.
We love sweat equity.
Yes.
We think if I suffer a little, if I put in the sweat equity, if I bow down, it must be accepted.
The universe has to reward my hard work.
But the text is saying your effort is entirely void if it is built on disobedience.
The sweat means absolutely nothing if you are running in the wrong direction.
And to completely anchor this concept, the master presents the reverse case.
The flip side of the coin?
Right.
He looks at lawful intimacy between a husband and wife.
To the
informed observer, to someone judging purely by outward appearances, this appears to be pure worldly indulgence.
Sure.
It looks like the satisfaction of a base physical appetite, entirely devoid of any spiritual merit.
It looks like the total opposite of fasting or praying.
But within the prophetic frame, it is the exact opposite.
Really.
Because it is done within the guidance, because it fulfills a right and honors a boundary,
It is obedience indistinguishable from prayer.
Indistinguishable.
Yes.
It is an act that earns actual spiritual reward.
This is such a critical analysis for you, the listener, to absorb.
It really shifts the paradigm.
It does, because there is no neutral act in your life.
None.
You are always either inside the frame or outside of it.
The framework is everything.
You can't just freelance it.
No.
You cannot say, well, I am a spiritual person.
I just do things my own way.
The universe does not accept your custom-built spirituality.
Exactly.
The same physical act of prayer is salvation at one hour and a sin at another.
The same physical act of intimacy can be a sin outside the frame and an act of high worship inside it.
The form must match the frame or the form is meaningless.
The master goes even further to state the historical reality of this framework.
What does he say?
He notes that this specific frame abrogated all prior religious dispensations.
Okay, so it replaced them.
Yes.
It is not just one valid option among a buffet of spiritual paths.
It is the singular culmination.
So you can't just pick and choose.
Right.
Any deviation from it is a departure from the truth.
The guardrails are absolute.
So the action must match the command, which brings us right back to the pivot, the spine verbatim.
Worship is another name for obedience.
We have established the dawn watch.
We have established the absolute non-negotiable necessity of the prophetic frame.
Now we must deal with the internal landscape required to actually sustain this.
Because knowing the rules is one thing.
Exactly.
Knowing that you shouldn't fast on Eid, knowing that you should wake up before dawn, that is easy to memorize.
But forcing the body to comply when every instinct is screaming for comfort.
When the bed is warm and the room is freezing cold.
Yeah, that is entirely another.
the frame is so absolute, what happens when we just don't want to do it?
When the body rebels.
Right.
You can't just politely ask your lower desires to step aside.
No, you can't.
And that's why the master introduces the inner condition, the sword of struggle.
He employs distinctly violent military imagery here for a very specific reason.
Because it's a battle.
Exactly.
You cannot advance on this path using accumulated knowledge alone.
Reading more books will not help you wake up at dawn.
No book is gonna pull the covers off you.
The lower self with all its desires, its rationalizations, its endless appetite for comfort and distraction and ego validation, it cannot be coaxed.
It cannot be negotiated with.
You cannot strike a bargain with your own laziness.
You really can't.
You can't tell your ego, let me have this one win today and I'll feed you tomorrow.
It must be severed.
Severed.
The master says it must be severed with a sword of inner spiritual struggle.
The internal resistance to obedience is incredibly fierce.
And sneaky.
Very sneaky.
Your lower self will actually use your own intellect against you.
Give me an example.
It will provide you with highly logical, deeply convincing arguments for why you should sleep in, or why you should delay your prayer, or why it's perfectly fine to indulge your anger just this once.
Right, I need the rest for my mental health.
Exactly.
It requires a force
forceful, disciplined, uncompromising response to cut through those rationalizations.
But what about the people who seem to bypass this struggle entirely?
Who do you mean?
Well, we all know people who look the part, who speak the language of spirituality effortlessly, who quote poetry and philosophy, but who clearly lack this intense grinding discipline behind closed doors.
The text is utterly ruthless regarding these false claimants.
Ruthless how?
The master details a precise polemic against false SOO fees.
Okay.
These are individuals who simulate the vocabulary and the outward posture of the path.
They act the part.
They learn how to sigh at the exact right moments.
Wow.
They learn to spin philosophical subtleties.
They talk endlessly about profound concepts, annihilation, divine love, the cosmos.
But internally?
Internally, they haven't swung the sword once.
They have the robes, they have the terminology, but their inner lives are just engulfed in moral darkness.
Yes.
They are simulating a destination they have never actually traveled to.
A tongue that speaks profound wisdom while the heart remains enslaved to petty appetites.
That is described as a mark of the gravest misfortune.
Because they're fooling themselves.
It is a terrifying state because the person actually begins to believe their own performance.
That's the danger.
The master is clearing the room of illusions here.
He emphasizes that the intimate knowledge of God does not dawn upon a person as a prize for reading books or mastering spiritual jargon.
It's not a certificate you earn.
No, it enters the heart only when genuine inner struggle has eradicated evil from the deepest recesses.
You have to actively clear the room for it.
is not an additive process.
Absolutely.
And we always want to add things, right?
Add a new habit, add a new book, add a new routine.
We love accumulating.
But you don't add more knowledge to a dirty vessel.
You have to scrub the vessel out with the sword of struggle before anything pure can even be poured into it.
Right.
And while some aspects of this journey, like the intense love, the tasting of spiritual realities,
are unspeakable.
They have to be experienced, not described.
Yes.
The practical steps to prepare the vessel can absolutely be codified.
And the master codifies them into the four conditions of the sincere seeker.
The 4 conditions.
These are not suggestions.
These are the non-negotiable prerequisites for walking the path.
Without these four, you are just wandering.
So let's go through these carefully because they are incredibly demanding and I feel like they expose exactly where most of us fail.
Let's do it.
What is the first condition?
Condition one is fear.
Okay, but what kind of fear?
We must be precise about this.
It is a fear of a law that is so absolute, so structurally sound within the individual psychology that it entirely prevents any drift into innovation.
It protects the bounds of the path.
Yeah.
Because why do we innovate in our spiritual lives?
We think we know better.
We innovate because we think we can optimize our worship.
We think, well, this traditional way is a bit dry.
Let me add this new practice.
Let me mix in this other philosophy to make it more meaningful.
Which stems
from arrogance.
Right.
If the fear is real, you will not dare to invent your own forms of worship.
You won't even think of it.
You will not dare to step outside the established frame because you recognize the absolute authority of the lawgiver.
The fear acts as a guardrail against your own ego.
Exactly.
Without that fear, the intellect just becomes a tool for justifying deviation.
Right.
Now, condition 2 addresses the past.
True repentance.
This is a repentance so complete, so structurally devastating to your old habits, that it closes the door entirely on returning to the humiliation of past sins.
So fear sets the boundary for the future.
But what about the baggage we already carry?
That's where repentance comes in.
Because fear stops future mistakes.
But it doesn't clean up the past.
No, it doesn't.
And true repentance isn't just feeling guilty.
Guilt is cheap.
Guilt is a passive emotion.
True repentance is an architectural change in your life.
What do you mean by architectural?
Like if your phone is the source of your sin,
True repentance means shattering the screen or deleting the apps, not just feeling bad while continuing to scroll.
Right, taking physical action.
It means severing ties with the environments and the enablers that pull you backward.
Precisely.
And then condition 3 shifts the focus outward.
To other people.
Yes, right, dealing.
You must satisfy even your enemies so that no creature holds an unfulfilled claim or debt against you.
This highlights the social requirement of the path, which is almost entirely overlooked when people focus purely on
personal spirituality.
We forget about other people entirely.
We love the idea of locking ourselves in a room and meditating.
It is clean.
It is quiet.
Nobody to annoy you.
Right.
But right dealing means your relationships with other human beings must be pristine.
You cannot be ascending in midnight prayer while you are defrauding your business partner or slandering your neighbor or holding an unjust grudge against an enemy.
The slate must be wiped clean with the creation if you want to approach the creator.
You can't bypass them.
The interpersonal debt is a chain that will drag you down no matter how much you pray.
Wow.
If you owe an apology, you must give it.
If you owe money, you must pay it.
The rights of others are fiercely protected.
That is a staggering requirement.
owe nothing to anyone, not even an apology to someone who actively hates you.
It takes immense humility.
The friction of humbling yourself to satisfy an enemy is the exact feeling of the sword of struggle severing the lower self.
That's the blade at work.
Then we arrive at the final condition, condition 4, which might be the most counterintuitive for a student.
Exact discipline of study.
Meaning what?
The requirement here is to acquire only enough sacred law to obey your personal obligations.
Wait, only enough.
Only enough.
To know exactly what you must do to fulfill your daily duties, how to pray correctly, how to fast, how to conduct your specific business lawfully.
But what about going deeper?
Beyond that, the pursuit of vast encyclopedic knowledge is a communal obligation, not a personal shield.
You study what you need to act.
I mean, we have an absolute addiction to information gathering.
We do.
We use studying as a procrastination tactic against action.
I just need to research a little more.
Yes.
We convince ourselves that we need to read 10 more books on the philosophy of prayer before we can actually wake up and pray.
But the master is saying that accumulating excess knowledge that you do not act upon just increases the evidence against you on the day of judgment.
That's terrible.
You are just building a bigger, more sophisticated library to be judged by.
You know exactly how the engine works, but you refuse to turn the key.
And to perfectly illustrate this filtration of knowledge to show how little we actually need to know versus how much we need to do, the master introduces
Okay, who is that?
This is a man who served 400 spiritual masters.
400.
He had access to absolute oceans of teachings.
He could have written volumes of intricate theology.
He had all the data.
Yet out of all of that, he adopted only one hadith out of 4,000.
Just one.
He found that the knowledge of the first and last generations was contained entirely within it.
Let's do the math on eternity right now.
Let's do it.
We need to recite the four proportions that the mystic extracted because they represent a complete reordering of how a human being calculates the value of their life.
Look at your own lifespan as we go through these.
Right.
The first proportion.
Work for this world in proportion to how long you will live in it.
If we look at an average lifespan, we are talking about
70, maybe 80 years.
A drop in the bucket.
In the grand scheme of time, it is a fleeting shadow.
And that completely shatters our modern anxieties.
We spend 50 years agonizing, destroying our health, compromising our ethics, just to secure a 20-year retirement.
We give everything to the numerator.
Yeah, exactly.
The second proportion, work for the hereafter in proportion to how long you wish to live there.
Eternity, infinity.
The Baghdad mystic realized that any mathematical equation where the denominator is infinity makes the numerator functionally 0.
The math is undisputed.
Your time on Earth is a rounding error.
Yet we invert the equation.
We work for the rounding error and ignore the infinity.
There's some madness.
The third proportion, work for Allah in proportion to your need of Him.
This is absolute dependence in every single breath.
Every breath.
The beating of your heart, the synapses firing in your brain, the oxygen in your lungs.
You are entirely, hopelessly dependent from microsecond to microsecond.
Your work, your devotion should match that level of desperate need.
And the final proportion.
Work toward avoiding the fire in proportion to how much you can bear its pain.
A capacity of absolute zero.
When you lay those 4 proportions out, the genius of the Baghdad mystic becomes overwhelmingly clear.
It's blindingly clear.
You do not need vast quantities of new knowledge.
You don't need 1000 different philosophical frameworks or 10 more lectures to listen to.
You really don't.
You need a very small set of teachings that completely reorder the shape of your reality.
If you actually calculated your daily effort based on those four metrics, your lifespan, eternity, your absolute dependence, and your zero capacity for the fire, every single decision you make would change the moment you walk out the door today.
It is the ultimate distillation of the master's message to his beloved student.
It is.
You don't need more books.
You need the inner spiritual struggle to implement the few sentences that contain everything.
And so we return for the final time to the spine verbatim.
Worship is another name for obedience.
We have covered a vast terrain today in this deep dive.
We really have.
We moved from the visceral somatic shock of the cold cup in the hand of the early Buzzran teacher into the heavily populated silence of the dawn watch.
We established the rigid, non-negotiable boundaries of the prophetic frame where form must match intent.
And finally, we drew the inward sword of struggle to meet the four rigorous conditions of the past.
Fear, repentance, right dealing, and discipline study.
I want to speak directly to you as you look at the hours and days ahead.
The nights are going to come.
The alarm clock is going to ring.
It always does.
If your standing with the Creator is measured not by the volumes of knowledge you have consumed, not by the cleverness of your arguments, but by the precise proportion of your inner spiritual struggle against your lower self, look at your life tonight.
Look closely.
Which of the four conditions
Fear that absolutely bars innovation, true repentance that permanently closes doors, settling debts with the creatures around you so your slate is clean, or acting strictly and only on what you already know, which of those will most demand the severance of your own comforts tonight?